hello everybody and welcome to drunk
minecraft with me Bob and Wade oh oh man
shut up shut up
zombie you busted it out way too early
I've got nothing now all right do your
throw I'll shut up I just I'll turn my
mic off no that was it we just did it
we're not live streaming doing again no
we're recording now
what do you are you William Shatner you
don't do more than one take no I don't
Bob I'm drinking beer
Bob's drinking what are you doing gin
and mostly chin dinna gin Wade obviously
a double Long Island
double double Long Island you have to
pay extra for that I made it myself so I
hope not can I eat glass I'm already
starving to death this is not going WAP
here fine take some bread how do you
have bread mark I lost everything
shut up Shh I stole bread don't take my
bread no I like an hour to get just some
wooden tools and from all gone I'm the
only one with bread you perv me or you
starve should we build a house or
something then let's build an underwater
house no more sand in my inventory
I've got 52 glass blocks Oh hold on hold
on hold on hold on we're like The Naked
toilets that are serving mold your tits
oh oh this tits
oh yeah whatever just hold on an
underwater house who can build the
gayest house you how to play mark
[Laughter]
Goodson you should pick better teammates
for this mark we're just gonna hang up
on you yeah we are
I have zombie on my side I could get him
to smite so I'll be able to go for us
over you zombie mold because you guys
didn't know
zombie mold for the people watching this
later not right now
let me mold is owner of the server
castle in the sky cactus maze some crap
with redstone diamond race it means fine
who finds for you you know giant chair
mansion a spaceship penis what kill you
know a spaceship penis except its penis
okay hey who did cuz I ain't your chair
who wouldn't fight it that guy shut up
it's like I don't know people like think
it's my thing I don't know kill NPC
villages with lava build a row like a
giant statue of me I like that one Vito
build the best murder machine wait you
know we could do two birds with one
stone and do a giant penis spaceship
statue and then put a big sign in front
of it that says this is also mark get it
what would be my name is with me a tiny
penis
I don't know all right us drunk to this
I see two Eiffel Towers and then you
jump off the Eiffel Towers in two giant
pits I don't know that one was confusing
- oh we all say happy birthday - Jen is
like fur Pam we gotta say happy birthday
to Jennifer yeah
no that's her name Jen a fur also known
as cheap Oh what the [ __ ]
zombie how what the [ __ ] happy for
killing some with bridge happy birthday
Jennifer what the [ __ ] her name
precisely
no her name was like chibi sugar on the
live stream or whatever I don't know on
in the chat she comments a lot on my
videos my name is chibi sugar kill happy
birthday chibi sugar Jennifer yeah Jen
no it's Jen Jen one word one word fur
what are you doing digging in the sand
I'm making a castle out of sand it's a
sand castle dick are you building a moat
in there too
I just could see here I got more on my
list shut up Minnie y'all's build a mini
golf court and Lord bursts the last one
shut up the last one burned down
villages in forests while taunting
Smokey the Bear and making inappropriate
jokes about Colorado I like that one
you like that one because we have to
start off by making a statue of Smokey
the Bear that's big enough to see from
where we're burning down villages before
we could just trap a bear and call him
smokey no that's too easy
I want to Smokey the Bear statue with
the yellow fireman's hat and the
overalls and the shovel or whatever the
[ __ ] he has zombie we need a Smokey the
Bear a costume there's no statue with
the yellow hat and overalls one of us
could be so I'll give it there we should
put a smaller than their costume on mark
and then we can just do what we were
gonna do anyway it's not conducive to
good minecraft behavior
okay don't even know what's not even
mean you're not minecraft pros like I am
I know I'm not a Minecraft pro you could
tell because I'm ticking sand with sand
all right I'm taking a long sip of this
drink so I'm gonna need it to last
through this we're going for a 45 minute
episode here so this is gonna be a
six-hour episode then no I got it it's
were like five minutes five minutes
we've not even done anything besides
read what we might do you it takes a
while yeah you're gonna have to cut some
of this out mark this Emily you uh it's
all staying in yeah this is a non
censored episode completely uncut this
is LA let's go swim with the squids
again that Kardashian show I don't know
how many are there I mean the one where
they leave all the pointless stuff in
and you know don't I am the squid king
I've never watched it so I wouldn't know
what you're talking about I'm gonna
build something useful by the way okay
I'm gonna be a sugar cone but by useful
I mean I'm gonna build a crafting table
I mean it was what what
I'm gonna get some wood so we can make
tools I got it and I got I've got a
hundred and some-odd wood right here
wooden place how I was cutting down
trees the whole time bob was digging his
sand fort and you were talking Shh shut
your face and I was [ __ ] ask me how much
I give a [ __ ] about what how much do you
give a [ __ ] about what you didn't finish
whatever you were gonna say shut up this
is my show and you all I what hello
everybody and welcome to Bob and Wade's
show where we invited mark very generous
of Marty thinking about breaking down on
our personal server that we host here we
allow some people to come in and be our
mod our personal man slave zombie mole
here he's here he likes it yeah he does
likes it
usually he's am I even recording in
Skype though I hope so I am okay I am so
that's good that's good
I need more it's needing more to drink
what huh
suddenly I found myself digging sand see
that's awesome it's just something to do
like I don't know well get some wood if
you need something to do I got I got
some wood I need it cobble about 58
wooden planks everybody needs any no one
gives [ __ ] I've got 15 or I say [ __ ] you
from this sure say it loud and say it
proud hey can I say ass rape [ __ ] anyway
other day really though rape isn't funny
no it's not it's not unless there's a
god unless what unless it happens to
guy apparently wait and then it's
hilarious what really I mean unless
you're really ugly can you really rape a
guy no I'm Dave Chappelle you know what
I'm talking about right Dave Chappelle
had a great bit about it was Dave
Chappelle oh boy
I am the joking bunch okay what what
okay you know the joking the jokey joke
King he's the joke Kings what he's
trying to say oh that's Koresh grass
over here is this dirt no it's grass
wait what was this dirt there was a sale
this is dirt the green stuff is dirt
grass damn it came out up where the big
yellow one is the Sun what hey there's
rock under war did you make a crafting
table say that's over here it's er it's
right here dope which ones real and
which ones mine what I got a cobble stop
making cobblestone I'm uh I'm with mark
on this one I don't think we're I don't
think I intended it for us just like
start this early in the game because
this is like ya know a new thing going
on there's nothing happening it is just
starting out new but I don't care
Oh give a [ __ ] right now cuz I got stone
tools so [ __ ] all you you suck your dick
I do well I got sandstone no one gives a
[ __ ] about your hand stone I do then
that's no one I am NOT I wish what I
wish I didn't have shitty tools zombie
give us 15 diamonds not mark though well
I have diamonds
I have diamond take away Mark's diamond
I have don't take my diamonds I have
diamonds hey wait I know how we could
get marks diamonds ah no you bugger oh
the [ __ ] I don't got a wooden sword of
zombie make it no wooden sword of
godliness damn it come on [ __ ]
diamond [ __ ] the diamonds in the middle
of the ocean yeah oh [ __ ] you didn't
stop me from gig to any more beer I
still have diamonds Tommy is zombie mold
still here could you be hi Maurice
you're here say hello hey it worked huh
still here there is not moving where'd
you guys go oh there you're here
suck it yep don't tempt me men zombie
take away my diamond tools I dig I'm
being poignant there they're gone
poignant poignant
I don't know what that means poignant
does that mean smelly
what I mean yeah yeah it means smelly
and gay it means both of those things
that's a really offensive word I didn't
think that's I wouldn't expect that sort
of word to exist huh what yeah it does
weird so are we gonna complete an
objective or what we got a large look
what I found
don't give a [ __ ] what hey
you're a son of a [ __ ] so I mean take
away take away Lord minion 777s also
known as Wade's a zombie you don't want
to do that no no we're going back
[Laughter]
damn it hey I got coal isn't that
incredible are you mining
yeah mining where are you my name is
this is just a little tiny hole that
what cobblestone down here Shh I got a
cobblestone Oh sand barking where are
you I made a hole yeah I'm a little too
well hey you
where's where's with what yeah we got
our own hole this is sorry you can't
come in we're girls allow me [ __ ] you
well were you gonna say ow you Oh
lagging get used to it
all right anyway are we gonna do one of
the objectives or what I don't know I
don't give a [ __ ] whatever I make it's
another drink alone all right mark pick
one you're the leader here pick one what
I gave you all the choices pick one I
thought you were the big bad boss man
statue of me okay Bob pick one statue of
mark but yeah this one that I was
talking about before is a tiny penis in
a chair for blue represent mark fog
larks Mark's favorite things [ __ ] I
shouldn't be laughing at that
you know laughing indicates acceptance I
shouldn't laugh at that but uh-oh cuff
way why cos tiny penises aren't funny no
serious epidemic the fact that you and I
walk around our boxers while Mark has
his own skins a little bed yeah I don't
know why you think you're in your boxers
because you're totally wearing a shirt
at pants on my screen yeah well that's
because Bob doesn't have a custom okay
I'm good the same thing mark ed what's
it called Sphinx banks you don't have
smacks now you have um police say it's
called Spanky do I think it's called
Spanky do I believe Spanky do
texturepack yes I believe yes this um
custom for zombies no no it's no it
means you're gay oh okay
hey Mark I think I know what we should
do what we should make an incinerator
that works Wow we always we always want
to make an incinerator and it's always
shitty and burns our house down yeah
remember how that happens yes doesn't do
that oh well then we need lava
I better dig straight down where my
feathers go
I'm a zombie you took everything yes
they're gonna be I'll be take everything
he has again take everything take
everything debit whatever he has I don't
care if it's wooden sticks take it away
take it away oh I found I found good
thing I found lava I love it I found
freaking diamonds I would not go in the
right way I don't I would I was right
here take I found it hang on I got get
ant torches hand I don't even have an
iron tools I can't get it but I found it
I'm afraid to get anything because
nothing everything's gonna disappear
don't cross me man do we have any
torches I do this I'm gonna do some work
and get some torches if you were invited
here just across you you know this yes I
know but don't cross me anyway I don't
want this growls not it iron here we go
oh this is like the best ever [ __ ] only
two I need are you mark I'm in a hole
which hole my hole
you know um Xue Jian pageant nur Oh
oh crap I found the [ __ ] zombie
Lourdes you you didn't even notice them
made it mom joke
ice no I totally totally blocked you out
for a while right okay that's like my
favorite sound the best birds we can't
see what's going on you could all see
you like here what are we doing I don't
know I'm digging for no reason yeah I
gotta cross off find the first diamond
because I won that one I didn't know
that was a thing I think we should turn
this into an epic have to finish all of
the things
Pepa sewed really that's good all of the
things in 45 minutes the idea was
have multiple episodes of this but if
we're just gonna have one I suppose it
can happen we should definitely have
multiple oh that was the idea but bob
says we should only have one
well I'm funny I did to the next ones oh
oh I think people might disagree with
that Bob I think I just fighter I'm
scared down here can you guys like you
know anything of Cole I'm good I can't
help you I got it oh yeah I'm gonna die
why haven't I make stone tools yet see
this is drunk is a terrible idea I'm
still using wooden tool I'm on fire
sounds like a personal problem in a good
way or a bad way
I'm tied oh so bad lawyer tried to swim
in a pool of lava shut up oh okay I'm
apparently Bob and I should be recording
so that people can actually watch some
quality playing oh my god I'm killing a
huge thing of zombies I'll get them down
here cuz I have my back's turned
I'm gonna push them in your hole damn it
why did I even say anything if you know
I was like I had thought of that is that
code push them in my hole nevermind oh
no oh oh no wow lord minion found one
Cole hey what I've got 16 Cole you found
one oh god damn it my chunks aren't
loaded where's blue mark needs Cho he's
got plenty of them that's why he needs
to work out what chunks shut up oh shut
up
hey light can I have a torch to - I know
you're gonna say no so I'm not gonna
finish asking zombie gear Bob drops into
one torch you're the best one torch
alone here your dick all my stuff burned
it on fire again
oh this is my favorite uh you know I
have to say mark I was trying to avoid
being all fanboy while we were recording
this but why did my whoa
why did my minecraft avatar turn into
some Asian guy you isn't it I swear my
thing turned into some asian guy like
you I know
but on mine it looks like some Asian guy
that's why mark I hate to point this out
man but that's you hey I need food mark
trust me bread I don't have any bread
anymore I died twice it's a pig kill it
wait mark you interrupted I was being a
fan huh
oh yeah say that video of yours where
the what the [ __ ] that on the lake
whatever that was huh that game to
Jerris like Panera bread's two numbers
that one yeah that that scare you've had
that was like the most epic scare of all
time yeah that was [ __ ] great oh no
girl walks in out of nowhere a girl I
don't know some zombie crazy zombie
slicey thing all right scared the piss
out of me it was I'm tossing someone's
charcoal on the ground here someone go
pick it up oh hey that's mine and stuff
I'm cooking this what why am i cold
whole pork chop idiot we need we're
gonna die there's like Enderman
everywhere I need to we we didn't even
build a house what is wrong with us you
have nothing we have no food the process
using wooden tools for summary is our
leader apparently that's working out
we're sitting it shut your face I don't
want any of your salad leader is the
Dead Guy
I need more beer I'll go get my loaf and
Ernest great leader hang on I'm gonna
get more beer you guys be entertaining
for a bit I stolen Oh stolen four
pickaxes stolen Oh what now
what now oh yeah okay
don't kill me I'm gonna go away for a
bit don't don't kill me
hey wait what man how's it going oh it's
going good how are you doing I'm good
who the hell is over here I thought this
was you know who is this what is this is
this is ami or something I don't know
I'm gonna leave it alone you uh case man
I hope so I hope it's something not
creepy wait come back me up orchids what
we're talking about so I guess no one I
want to attack it oh yeah sand let's get
him over here in front of all my god
what's happening I don't know it's
looking at me
Oh we're digging your own grave we're
not this is like that community episode
where what what is this thing that's a
villager why would you do it I don't
know because it's a village I don't know
Oh No is that oh that Latin goddess
where's that zombie I hope it's one of
the two cuz it's just kind of staring at
us
hey I've got one heart and no food no
one gives a [ __ ] hey save me I've got
some bread wait do you want some yes
I'll give you torches torches you're
gonna have to do better than that
I find this acceptable good enough worm
I want to do that Sunday in real life
okay we're like what do you give me for
this chop chop chop we're going we're
like 25 minutes in and we've not done
shits
we haven't done [ __ ] so we got let's go
all right what you doing we need a house
build a giant chair [ __ ] the house build
a chair sand chair out of wood got ass
and I'd be amazed class chair
yes all right we need we have a fungal
fan we need more coal use wood yeah
charcoal yeah that hold advanced
minecraft recipe of charcoal hey it is
advanced shut your mouth I'm gonna make
like three more furnaces why so we can
make a fuckload of glass all at once
do we have coal I've got some coal and a
bunch of wood ok then I'm going to make
cobblestone pick us after I lost all my
[ __ ] after I lost my iron because I was
on I just did stuff at you here mark
hold no no this wood crap get this out
of here it's for you I'm tossing it in
the ocean good I want your viewers to
watch you mindlessly throw crap in the
water
I will oh this is why you can't have
nice things just so you know shut up
these aren't nice things I know but this
is why you can't have them
I got a complete set of whatever alright
we're gonna make this chair epic I'm
gonna start off with dirt that sounds so
epic man so epic indeed that villager is
still there he's creepy as hell yeah
it's like got bangs different for your
texture pack he looks like a job jump
from Star Wars a jump job you know the
you know a chop job you know the traitor
thingies ja wohl yeah that nothing job
job you could see the relation oh shut
up
hey Jason Star Wars at least once in
your life you know it's not a job job
I've seen it many many times I thought
it we've enough
first I thought it was a job job I'm
questioning my subscription all of a
sudden you can leave anytime you want
done marry me I'm busy I'm helping on
our villager here through there there
sir blur ah shut up
wait furnaces now well isn't this
fantastic there's nothing to put in them
I have a fuckload of sand all we need is
some wood what the hell he's digging his
way out you okay over there Wade you
okay good
you okay don't mind this I don't mind
that okay
zombie can I get a full stack of TNT
enough flint and steel well here goes
the chair before get please yes please
yes full stack of TNT Flint steel oh my
lord
minion I do think he's listing heya
flint and steel
what no give it to ball zombie can we
get marks surrounded by TNT cut if you
just give it to me I'll do it
can we dot I have the power
please dear turn God hold on for Bob and
I please no just just me just Bob I
don't even care if I I just Bob all
right what the [ __ ] kind of chair is
this happening four legs wait who let we
decide the chair hey Mark you I see
something funny what a bag whatever
whatever just do it I don't care
my body's lived I live
[ __ ] yeah 49 TNT I didn't get [ __ ]
we should justly should do we should
just mine like this with TNT and got it
I got it and I picked up someone's
corpse hey zombie like oh no P I do it
right like I did I found this TNT fair
and square
so I'll be gave me thirty two teen teen
I used it all on mark he gave you 30 200
how do you say mark where's Bob at you
should take a look at it oh no zombie
this is what I thought I have why am i
dying you're on fire why did she just
light me on fire
zombie why did you give them the tools
and not me you wanna see something scary
what Bob that's our stuff Bob that's our
furnaces Bob what the hell why are you
both on fire burning objectiveness
we're supposed to be doing something for
oh hey guys oh hey come here come here
I'm building myself a house good beer
what can't I do anything like it I can't
do them zombie nabe it's not working
here we go how did that not blow by TNT
house oh you ass bag oh no did someone
pick up the did someone pick up the
creeper stuff oh [ __ ]
who got him no one god I mean just blew
up all that TNT that I said okay where's
marker I'm back now he died a little bit
I'm back oh can I get more of those
things so he took of all I picked them
up he took them away yeah it's the first
one it's not supposed to be productive I
tried to hug a creeper because I love
creepers there might [ __ ] where am I
how do you get back I'm the greatest you
can't kill me Bob zombie kill pop kill
him dead no zombie can kill me you can't
oh okay
ass bag down here this TNT blows anybody
have any tools I have to
and the Flint and stuff there's iron
down in that pit yes there's tons oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh what's that you seem
to be in pain no I can't I kill you I
can't I quit you I cannot quit you
bambam yapple well viewers I apologize
for Marc's lack of leadership
wait don't apologize Marc sucks hey I
apologize for Martin I'm leaving
Marcus the best it's sucking your weight
I'm gonna help you mine okay all right
wait wait wait wait I don't like this I
have an idea of how you might be helping
me MA Oh get out I don't think these
creepers are as useful as TNT but I
better sponge them anyway
oh no I can't make my tea and tea light
anymore I break my flint and steel no it
still works
nowhere you guys are a demon am i dying
I killed Bob I killed him dead i herded
him because anybody actually gonna watch
this crap why are you not buried what
what do you mean are people gonna watch
this everyone's gonna watch maybe I
don't know all right if anybody actually
likes this
you gotta like and favorite and comment
that this was awesome yeah all right I
challenge you to a duel what with what
I'm right behind you a creeper duel oh
no I killed it that's not good
good job there are two more boom dress I
pushed you to death I punch you too dear
okay anyway um we're we um doing
anything no we do anything we're gonna
make a chair that turned into this pit I
don't know who did that hey no I am NOT
streaming
a zombie can we import it somewhere else
we kind of destroyed this place no
zombie we're good just give us all TNT
shut up we're gonna go somewhere where
we can actually start a legit we're
destroying his entire server hello
I got ported 10 feet away what the hell
is [ __ ]
zombie does entertainment better than
you do more shut up I'm it's my youtube
channel it's alright oh man
more beer oh yeah yeah we need to get
more drunk this is this is good you all
want to go to be Tubbs after this who's
driving oh yeah that's right actually
you know what we're probably good Tyler
to drive me oh that's too much trouble
and we got a record more after this or
something I don't know I probably
shouldn't be telling all my viewers this
this is supposed to be behind the scenes
stuff Zack I'm busy Zack oh well I'm
playing Minecraft you need a drink
I need a drink Zack it's gonna have to
wait a while brother no no I'm not
making drinks for you before you drive
I'll get you one later Zack Zack oh [ __ ]
whoa yay whoa I'm on a mountain aha we
got porn okay now we're gonna be serious
all right
I'm gonna build the house on the top of
the mountain you guys get some torches
you got like all minutes left we're gods
and Mark episode 1 get to be extended
we're gonna be serious I got iron to
mark you should release extended cuts of
these episodes what's to be extended you
know all the good stuff that we're gonna
do later would I don't have any would I
have one block of sand
it's that helpful yeah I've got 64
blocks of sand while someone [ __ ]
killed me I've got 22 gold coal 64 sand
and 9 iron
you've cold cold cold cold
holy always I'm closed wasteful to burn
that we need I'm gonna go get some wood
he wipes his ass with diamonds which
hurts really bad apparently is awesome
for me okay anyway we're gonna be totes
serious totemic goats votes okay what
are we doing well you know what I want
to do oh god I want to blow up my town
I'll blow it all up
we should can we just like what are you
doing all right try to get wood and I've
got swarmed with what I receive are you
bastard what do I have good stuff
what is wrong iron boar beer oh why
don't I have good stuff anymore
I need food I keep randomly getting and
then loosing things I am starving to
death this is a really weird Minecraft
thing shut up it's fine okay where there
you are Wade I need five okay
I'm digging build a farm get bone
meeting would get bone meal in a
crafting table I'm gonna get bone meal
I'm gone I had a bone I think somebody
took it cuz you can't do [ __ ] I'm gonna
get I'm gonna kill these skeletons and
then
Hey look this but where's your footy ad
what I'm on top of the mountain building
our house oh I don't even know what
mountain you're on now I'm gonna climb
this one I hope it's the right one
what just so you know our house is
really shitty it's only two blocks wide
inside yeah well I didn't have a lot to
work with
oh it's just at least it's nice in
length
Tribune oh it's doesn't that much in
girth but you know it makes well hey
it's how you use it
mark yeah it does true very everybody
have cobblestone ah I just gave away my
cobblestone I'm gonna get it I'm gonna
get the cobblestone hand well we need um
wha complete your sentences I don't
remember my father mark we made it we
did it
why don't get it I'm getting it what are
you getting luck I know it we need it
yeah we're so well-prepared we've got a
list of objectives that we're just
ignoring working on a house so that we
could build a chair I don't even think I
should have the webcam in here this is
this is ridiculous
I I think I better remove your leg Kim I
don't know why would you remove your
webcam I don't know everyone wants to
see how stupid you look while you play
that sounded meaner than it did in my
head I will shove a rake up your anus oh
my god I know my prey that service
entire rate up Uranus you know normally
you've got to pay for stuff like that
yeah I heard you the first time
okay copy cotton hot from dodgeball I
thought you were never mind
no oh I like I dunno I like cotton I
didn't think of him cotton the guy in
the wheelchair no that's Pachamama tater
patches is the guy in the wheelchair
I thought chuck norris was a commentator
no he's a judge idiot
how do you not know these things oh oh
[ __ ] me then okay crafting table right
here the worst house I've ever seen it's
gonna be a flag house okay we're gonna
have a hovering dirt house no it's gonna
be glass I'm putting a furnace and
making glass oh that's good
what does that sound Oh creeper exploded
my bone Julian creepers what's going on
Bobby don't give them food no zombie
come on Latin goddess I need food shut
up I'm gosh can't help you gummy bear I
need food and can't help you somebody
give me food shut up
zombie give me TNT zombie give him
nothing give me a stack of TNT and flint
and steel so I can blow up this travesty
of a house Marc did you even see the
house that you made I'm looking at it no
this is the house that I made I mean the
house that you made so stupid and awful
it didn't have a roof it's like the
house I grew up in really that's so sad
for you
that is so depressing if my parents are
subscribers to your YouTube channel they
are gonna be so confused okay anyway
gummybear I need food please Lord minion
777 needs food
Lord minion 777 eat [ __ ] I you gave me
one TNT one that's too much take it away
it'll have to do go boom [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
your house just one what's so pathetic
what's like the most anymore
ow what the [ __ ] I thought that was mark
that's my bad
no there's a creeper God are you almost
dead of hunger you dick burn in hell
burn in hell I can't thank God Mode I
think I did good god mo zombie take oh
yeah I've got mode disabled what the
hell yes oh not fair not fair I still
eat all what we just spawned in the
middle of death okay
don't care I don't care hey zombie Bob
and I need lots of diamond equipment and
TNT and food I shut up
we're I can't believe the sapling isn't
killing that spider sadly maybe we
shouldn't play a Minecraft we should do
like ah a game where we can't kill each
other shut up oh wait you're actually
trying to kill me no oh it's no later oh
no oh no you yes that's right I'm dead
iron stuff and I [ __ ] your [ __ ] up yep
I'm the winner I'm the best I'll be not
listening to us cuz I'll be not never
gonna listen to you
I just ate rotten flesh it was all my
glass not me what all the stuff I
dropped by I died somebody gives it
about you and anything you do well
that's kind of depressing it is isn't it
I know all of your viewers care about me
mm-hmm zombies what huh I'll be your in
this Skype call what are you talking
about what are you talking about missing
okay anyway um we're actually almost out
of time
for this yeah we're I think we're out of
time actually yeah I think we're done I
think that's it for the first episode
Bob this is the worst first episode of
all time Bob are you there yeah we might
be done oh I'm too frayed for a second
[Music]
I'm drinking to this I couldn't even see
what was happening
I still can't see what's happening I'm
so dead oh yeah cuz I died and all I see
are pretty colors why do I keep spawning
here I don't like this place oh man
climbing the waterfall one frame per
second I'm attacking this apartment
building good for you oh wow zombie can
I join them did I get banned my band no
you're you're on you're on you might a
gun okay Oh Magda holy [ __ ] what the
hell how is something where did the
water come from exist was it anyway
that's gonna do it for this episode
thank you all so much for watching if
you like drunk minecraft let us know let
us know what you think of the comments
below and if you want more guess what
you didn't Bob and Mark like yeah this
has been me my friends Bob and Wade here
entertaining you so if you liked it let
us know in the comments and if you want
more let us know so thank you all so
much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next part
Hey say bye-bye everybody
there we go I refuse [ __ ] you Bob bye
bye bye